so i'm sitting there like all right here
we go finally it's all it's all
happening
and he goes uh we we hit a snag we
really love you we think you're a star
but we're not taking white guys
i miss the old days you know when you
just treated people by how they were you
know someone was a dick you're a dick to
them someone's nice you're nice now
they're like oh i don't think so
i said is that company policy and he
said uh yeah it is
and so you know i hung up and i was
crushed
you have to look at their skin color
their gender there's a whole checklist
of things you have to do before you even
say hello to somebody it makes you crazy
lots of sleepless nights and and a lot
of pain and
having some of my heroes hate me people
don't want to know your story right they
can attack you but nobody knows what
i've gone through and survived you're
gonna reach a point and it's gonna
likely be financial or you were a job
was taken away or your daughter's job
it's like the people that come after me
i go well what if yeah what if your
white daughter was told [ __ ] off you're
white you can't be an actor you know the
pendulum will swing back and i'm going
the pendulum is broken out of the
[ __ ] clock and it's just like
slamming everyone in the head
hello and welcome to a very special
episode of trigonometry on the road from
the usa i'm francis foster i'm
constantine kissing and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today in what is a very hot studio
hence why we are all dressed like we're
in hawaiian beach somewhere
is a brilliant comedian podcaster
youtuber a little bit controversial at
the moment because he's suing a
potential manager uh for saying he can't
work with him because of his race
we can't talk about that um so uh tyler
fisher welcome to trigonometry thanks
for having me it's great to have you
here man we're in new york uh which is
where a lot of cool comedy stuff is
happening uh tell everybody before we we
get into all of that who are you how are
you where you are what has been the
journey through life that leads you to
be sitting in that chair this chair
right here francis snuck into my dms
took me out to coffee he does that all
right i took him out to starbucks which
is a bit of a letdown
uh so yeah i am a comedian actor
i started in
a
theater
theater and then studied uh actually
studied in london a little bit
dropped out
of uh of acting school in london could
not couldn't take the the theater kids i
don't know if you've you've been around
them yep i have it's they're like the
cousin of comedians and a little it's
all kind of wretched it up a little bit
moved to new york city started doing uh
film tv stand-up theater and then i
started making my own sketches
my own
videos
and now i'm a touring comedian and and
living the dream
living the dream indeed and you know
your sketches are brilliant like some of
the stuff you did during the pandemic
about
vaccines and all of that it's really
good
hi this is a little message to the
unvaccinated
you are killing everyone it's your fault
you're being selfish so get the vaccine
because i'm vaccinated i am vaccinated
okay and so i'm protected because the
vaccine is safe and effective so if
you're around me and you're unvaccinated
then you're putting me up
well you're not you're
okay so you're selfish because if i'm
protected and you're around me then i
then i'm fine but you're but you're me
sorry if you're not vaccinated then
you're not it's your
um
you're racist is what i'm saying
it's it's really good and you're a great
impressionist as well but the one of the
reasons we wanted to have speaking of
impressions i heard mark norman was just
here i can still feel his hey hey hey
comedy
what are we doing
is that why this is the tears all torn
up because he moves around what are we
doing i love mark yeah mark's great uh
but one of the reasons we wanted to have
you on is obviously this situation with
you and a potential
agent manager um
where you were about to
get signed they they said they really
liked you and then they were like we
can't work with you because you're a
white guy yeah and they're going to use
this clip because it is about 100
degrees in here and i'm sweating yeah so
i'm picturing in a year when we're in
court they're going to cut to this clip
and go look at him he's sweating through
it he's probably lying about all of it
uh
yes yes so what happened so what
happened i
this has been happening for about 10
years every once in a while a casting
director would say hey you know i want
to submit you for this job but we're not
really doing the white guy thing right
now
okay that's interesting
and it it happened more and more
frequently
i i'd be booked on a podcast get a text
hey not the best time to have a white
guy on yeah sorry about that
yeah thanks
guys yeah you guys weren't even famous
yet
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
british white is [ __ ] up or you seem
tan yeah exactly
are you i'm uh so i'm originally from
russia but okay the the face is like
greek and jewish okay
you know it's funny i auditioned for a
uh animated voice today and i was
telling you guys and uh the description
was 30 caucasian
but the guy looked like you but darker
right so now they won't even show white
guys as white yeah that's become a
little yeah you've got to be a at least
tanned yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
don't want someone who's actually white
or white and sweating
that's
but you know what can you have the
temperature on the screen during this
just so that people understand that's
what we need but it's funny the way
you're talking about it's doing great
everything's great career is going great
[Laughter]
but you know what i find interesting
about the like the way you just
mentioned my skin tone right yeah to me
i love that because there's no
awkwardness about it like yeah we have
different skin color and we can just
talk about it but we've certainly in the
uk like if you'd made that comment
everyone be like
like he's mentioned my skin color oh
yeah yeah i just got shamed for that uh
well not even for me it was uh all white
people do this thing and it was directed
at me
and i was like well what what's the
problem with that you meet somebody you
don't have much to talk about at a party
it's like where'd you get the shoes
where are you from yeah
you know you take that out there's not
much left so it's a good conversation
starter anyway back to the story back to
the lawsuit right for eight for 10 years
you've noticed that every now and again
you apply for something you know and
they're like we're not doing the white
guy thing at the moment yep constantly
one of the biggest jobs i i actually got
i won't mention it but uh it was a
casting director who i knew personally
she was a fan of mine um and she they
them those i don't wanna
gotta be careful there too uh and she
wrote to me she said i probably
shouldn't submit white guys for this
but i have a feeling you're a perfect
fit so i'm going to sneak you in
and again i mean to look at that then i
start to feel like well i i don't
deserve it why
the the job had nothing to do with race
or gender or anything
and i booked the job
and every day i went and i did feel a
little bit like am i stealing this from
somebody because of the way she
presented it um so yeah it just happened
more and more and then
i had an agent bring me in big agent in
new york
he goes why aren't you on snl every year
around two months before snl people
would bring me and go why aren't you on
snl aren't you famous and i'm like well
if you know if you want to help me out
that'd be great
i don't have lauren's
whatsapp
so
a few months later radio silence and i
emailed i said what's what's going on no
auditions nothing and he wrote back
and i quote tough out there for white
dudes and then they
they removed me from the roster i got an
email and said you've been removed so i
was i was done
so then i i just stopped pursuing agents
and managers for a while started making
my own stuff
this agent
that i am suing or manager rather
reached out and
said we love you we want to get you
auditions for kirby enthusiasm all this
stuff and
um
said great
a few months later they reach out said
we want to call we want to get you on
the phone so i'm sitting there like all
right here we go and finally it's all
it's all happening
and he goes uh we we we hit a snag we
really love you we think you're a star
but we're not taking white guys
and i was just like what the f you know
been at this for 15 years
not that i deserve anything you know if
i went my whole career without getting
booked on something but i at least had
the opportunity to audition i'd feel
okay about that but
what's happening now is they're removing
certain races from even having the
opportunity
to compete and that's what a manager or
an agent is they get you the opportunity
to compete that you otherwise can't
unless you have
you know a big youtube show like you
guys
so i'm sitting there and i remembered my
therapist uh i was dating a quite
mentally unstable woman at the time and
he said you need to start recording
conversations if anything comes up
because you don't want to be accused of
the million things you can be accused of
and so i hit record
i said can you say that one more time
you know you like me yeah you think i'm
a star yeah but you won't work with me
because i'm white and i was like can you
say it a little slower
a little slower
and uh i said is that company policy and
he said uh yeah it is
and so
you know i hung up and i was crushed you
know i wanna i wanna sit here and
pretend like i i it didn't bother me but
i cried
you know it was like this the little kid
when their balloon is just you know
getting taken away into the sky it's
like i saw my career just
i tried everything you know i worked 12
hours a day seven days a week i do all
the shows i i've been making sketches
and i just thought without this
gatekeeper i'm not gonna make it
and so um i didn't just go out and sue
them and i mean i worked with my
therapist for
for months on this and and uh decided to
to finally pursue it because i thought
it'll kill me if i don't yeah i was i
was losing my mind francis i know you
want to jump in and i just want to
finish this one thing real quick and
then have at it i actually have to go
right now
we'll just cut it there no but the
reason i the thing i wanted to say
before francis you take over is this
when i saw the story that this had
happened with you
it kind of made me laugh you know why
because you're racist exactly
uh
i hate white people uh in the uk that's
no longer racist mate yeah that's yeah
that's progressive yeah but in the uk
this is going on all the time yeah i had
i remember an incident where i i had
someone was not racist to me in the
street right and that day i got home
when i got into what was the race was it
white or no no it was dark oh
because you you're right i can i can go
either way this is my point right same
day i get home that evening i get an
email from a promoter saying i'm sorry
we're gonna have to change your dates
because there's too many white people on
the bill so i've just been
do you see what i'm saying
right and francis will tell you as well
this is like it would never occur to
anyone on the uk comedy scene to sue a
manager or an agent who'd said that yeah
because it's it's just taken for granted
now it's normal it's normal it's beyond
normal it's so normal that they're
comfortable saying it even with a little
laugh you know i believe he had a little
giggle
you know you know the pendulum will
swing back and i'm going the pendulum is
broken out of the [ __ ] clock and it's
just like slamming everyone in the head
i don't want to hear the pendulum
analogy you know or any you know
analogies from the
1800s or whatever uh so
yeah
it's it you don't think this stuff would
happen
uh given the
perpetual
sort of
beating over the head of you have to
stand up for discrimination you have to
stand up for oppression and i'm all
about that but then i go wait it's
happening to me
and they're going not that not that not
that kind
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
but that's the interesting point isn't
it because if this had happened to a
black person
you would go that's disgusting and quite
rightly
yes sorry person of color
and you you would go that's disgusting
and quite rightly yeah it's just
nobody bats an eyelid
yeah
no it's it's justified
racism or discrimination it's not
reverse
you know you can't we can't use these
fake made up woke words like cisgender
to reverse you know
it's not it's it it's exactly what it is
it's the same definition white people
didn't invent racism
you know go to asia
[Music]
that's funny yeah so so
i just made the decision i'm not playing
this game anymore i'm gonna i'm gonna go
for it
and and i and i also waited until i had
my until i made my career on my own so
it was calculated that i didn't want to
get sucked into that victimhood
mentality because that's also a billion
dollar business at this point yeah so i
thought all right if i build up my
following i'm making a living i can pay
rent i can tour
then i'll do this when i have the the
strength you know and obviously you went
out you talked about this and the entire
comedy community went that's a fellow
comedian that's my brother we've got to
stand up for him
yes that
that did
uh where where did that happen
what platform was it on instagram
it must have been on my uh myspace
that's where all the support was yeah uh
no no no
to nobody's surprise there was um
there was very little support uh
the support i get is in a comedy club
when i'm walking out a comic will tap me
on the shoulder and look around and go
love what you're doing i love what
you're doing
and that's about it i'll get a whisper
so
i had to sacrifice
my standing in the in the comedy scene
and and i did and so um yeah i'm called
crazy insane far right all the
all the words you can possibly think of
on that
that side of the political spectrum
which this isn't political at all
nor are most things that that people
find controversial
so
yeah that's that's the new normal for me
i go into a comedy club people some
won't look at me some won't shake my
hand but i have to
[Music]
kind of rise above it transcend it and
what do you think that is why do you
think comedians
who are meant to be the ones championing
free speech championing the right to
joke about whatever you want
because even if you're
selfish you've got to realize that this
will come and affect you
it may not be today may not be next
month even next year but eventually it
will affect you why are they not
standing up and pushing back against
this nonsense
well let's ask them we have mark norman
right here hey hey comedy come on
uh
it's
there's a lot of reason i want to look
up i know i'm a big jordan peterson guy
it's like you got to look up to the
stars and you got to take personal
responsibility
got to clean your damn room
and jordan peterson's actually one of
the one of the reasons why i spoke up
about this because he
uh
defended the right to not be compelled
to use preferred pronouns and if you
don't know jordan peterson um they do
losers yeah yeah it's like you eat a
lobster
he when he stood up to that i i
i hadn't really seen anybody really
stand up for something so common sense
and logical you see the protests and the
vague
sort of um umbrella protest terms and
all that so when i saw him do that i
thought okay
uh
if i don't do this this is gonna take me
under so so
that inspired me to speak out and then
also watching his journey i was kind of
prepared to to see
he didn't get any support very little to
none from the from psychologists or from
his
his industry
he was eaten alive
but the the common sense people in
society were the ones that came to his
defense
and that might be 80 or 90
of the population so that's pretty good
so i thought all right i'm gonna
probably lose
this group of comedians maybe some of my
family
some of my friends my girlfriend my dog
my apartment
my mind
but apart from that but apart from that
i'll ha i'll have uh pride
and so
i think one of the reasons a lot of
comedians don't
won't stand up for this is just fear
we've now created this fear of things
you can't talk about it's all [ __ ]
it's all made up you can talk about it
at your own risk and so that bubble is
getting bigger and
discrimination against white people is
now in that thing where you they go nope
because they changed the definition in
the i think webster
dictionary
where racism is not
uh a real thing against white people
and
people are buying into this stuff so i
think it's fear it's fear and and
comedians are are uh you know
we typically don't make a lot of money
most aren't successful most won't have a
career so then if you speak up and you
defend somebody who's
seen as controversial you might lose
your spot at the comedy club and then
the other person might find out so
the fear is so deep
where i don't think most people are
willing to uh
to do it and then the ones that kind of
attack me for it well it's
i don't you know while they're doing
that i'm just writing and producing and
filming and enjoying my life so
but the interesting thing is the
comedians that we all looked up look up
to like i know you're a huge george
carlin fan
they're the ones who went well i'm gonna
say what i say and [ __ ] it and
damn the consequences
that's what makes a great comic you know
and i think for a lot of these
communities if they actually truly
understand that and we're brave enough
to make that step their lives would be
transformed now it wouldn't it wouldn't
be easy it's not the easiest path to
take and it certainly wouldn't be
without you know negative consequences
but ultimately there's a freedom at the
end of the journey like george carlin or
richard pryor or hicks or any of these
people none of them took the easy path
sure but how many are there total
you know you just listed on one hand
yeah may there might be two hands worth
yeah and so it is incredibly uncommon i
think
and it might have to do with your
personality type or
uh how you were brought up i'm not sure
but
i think but it is a tremendous amount of
pain to get out out of it you know i
know you you and i spoke about that
um
it it's not fun
and so it's tempting to to want to go
around that and then go you know play by
the rules
but you're never going to live a life
where you're fulfilled like you said
where you have pride in yourself where
you actually love what you do and
creating the work that you truly want to
create if you go down that other path
even if you become the snl the whatever
it is that you want yeah it's always
going to feel slightly dirty right
because you know you compromised yeah
yeah and that was one of my dreams and
now i
if they walked in and said we want you
on this saturday i would
say thanks but no thanks [ __ ] lorne
sorry man you're gonna be coming out it
was a big surprise
[ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah what's interesting about your
case though is you you actually saw what
was going to happen because uh i don't
know if you know this but in in 20 the
very end of 2018 i got offered a
contract to do a gig at a university
which said they have a zero returns
policy on like a gazillion things races
and it said that all jokes have to be
respectful and kind and whatever and i
turned it down and it became quite a big
story without me knowing that it would
and then i i was so naive man i thought
here i am like taking one for the comedy
world yeah for the comedy like i'm
saying in your dms yeah i'm like yeah
where's the praise yeah well when do
they
and then i went back
and i went into the green rooms
and like half the people wouldn't look
at me
the other half jimmy fair would come and
give me a hug and say well those are the
half that think you're brown the other
half right you're white exactly
exactly divide it into two and but like
i was so incredibly naive but you seemed
to like you knew what was coming if you
did i did but there's no way to
there's no way to actually conceptualize
that and feel what it feels like no to
you know i the the woman that um
uh
said i'm gonna sneak you into that
audition though you're white and i
shouldn't i saw her about a block from
here the other day i walked by i said hi
how are you she looked at me and she
goes
and and my friend goes what the [ __ ] did
you do to that woman
and i go nothing she got me a job and
now you know so there's no way and that
you know it still hurts i had to kind of
pull over to the side and like he had to
go you know mate you okay
and uh i had to get go get an ice cream
and stuff but yeah to have that happen
there's no way to prepare for it but
most people just like in their stance on
everything else are cowards so they're
not gonna say anything to me
not one person yeah out of
the you know 100 million views i've
gotten on my videos not one has come up
to me in person and said
you're you know a terrorist or piece of
[ __ ]
so
you've got to separate the internet from
reality yeah and you think you in some
ways we're incredibly fortunate in that
people who did what you do and what we
do 100 years from now they would have
been burned at the [ __ ] stake whereas
yes you didn't get the opportunities
that you wanted in some ways and you're
taking the punishment for making a stand
on a thing that you believe in
but at the same time you can make your
own content
you're
very funny you're getting opportunities
online that you create for yourself and
that is a tremendous privilege the
people who wanted to challenge the
status quo who wanted to
point out that the emperor's naked 100
200 300 years ago they never had that
opportunity and we do well if they were
men they had privileged regardless
haven't you heard
men even with the life expectancy of 14
years old were
were so incredibly privileged
so i loved someone said that to me
recently like
men have always had all the jobs and
everything and i was like do you think
there was a feminist in like 1600 who
was picketing to have like more female
cobblers or
female you know candlestick makers or
whatever
uh
yeah i guess so but this does take
people out yeah this cancel stuff takes
people out sure and uh
i just have something maybe it's from
being bullied as a kid for being
short or whatever it is
i think i have a little extra something
that's just this little you know
pilot flame that's just always on no
matter how
down and out i am that i don't think
most people have so i think whatever my
privilege is is this biological thing
that all of the short men in my family
have had to you know
overcome i'm glad you said that man
because i think for francis and i
the the reason we do what we do is also
partly because
like
i i i'm not prepared to let people bully
me or other people
i'm just not
and
when i see unfairness
even if other people are okay with it
i'm not okay with it you know and i
think that's kind of where you're coming
out of it well you're a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's what you would say yeah
but you know what i mean like you you're
just not prepared to be quiet about
something you think is important no no
because the feeling the the the
alternative
is too
powerful
you know i know how that feels right to
not stand up even when i was bullied
yeah i remember a guy tried throwing me
in the trash can and i like got his legs
and like you know kind of got him and we
were like kind of both in the trash can
success yeah
and i mean that's twitter isn't it yeah
well yeah and uh you know
in my that was
you know the day my dad uh left my mom
but but i had him in the trash can
pretty good
you're not going anywhere dad
uh and my dad did leave my mom for for a
man my dad came out of the closet when i
was a kid and i think that you know it's
it's kind of like try me peop people
don't want to know your story right they
can attack you but nobody knows what
i've gone through and survived
and so
that's a
misstep to not
to just go even if you know i have
friends
will go what the hell happened to you
you know friends from from a few years
ago or 10 years ago
uh but i'm like you you don't know you
don't know anything that happened that
led up to that even with the agent a lot
of comedians you know attacked me for it
and i go yeah you never asked any other
questions like has this happened before
is this the first time the tenth time
um
so
i guess that's kind of my super powers
like i have that history of of uh
overcoming this stuff
and
if somebody isn't isn't interested in
that then
they're not somebody i want in my life
and with this freedom what is it what
has that done for you creatively with
the knowledge that you don't have to
pander to gatekeepers you're not worried
about what the comedians think what has
that done for you in your world well it
landed me a sketch show on cnn plus
and there's one episode
no it's it's the ultimate freedom i mean
there's no i i it's a feeling i didn't
even know existed until you're there
right and
again not easy like lots of sleepless
nights and and a lot of pain and and
having some of my heroes attack you know
hate me is
quite a thing to have comedians i looked
up to since i was a kid
some of which you know
do you want can we talk about that i i
won't i'm not going to say any names yes
because that's one of my rules i don't i
just don't gossip yeah um
which is a useful
tool i think especially if you're in the
heat to go no matter what happens i
didn't talk [ __ ] about any of them yeah
i think that that's been a really
helpful tool but yeah but should have
done that yeah we should later yes
and he's in that guy he's a [ __ ]
prick
yeah i just there's too many pricks out
there to to comment on yeah so it
depends how much time you go yeah
you're right yeah yeah no it's a good
rule man
yeah yeah but no some comedians that i
looked up to that you know
really started you know sharing my stuff
and and who now think i'm
you know
uh storming the capital or something or
whatever the hell
you know
it's pretty wild yeah but it's also a
blessing because now my heroes
i don't have to look up to anyone yeah
but the freedom is it's unbelievable
you know it allows you to to cross the
line
maybe way farther than you should
but you have to do that you know there's
no
there's no other way to do it as as a
comedian our job is is done publicly the
the
trials and tribulations is public
there aren't a lot of other jobs like
that and most people don't
see comedy and understand hey we're
actually just rehearsing all this stuff
live publicly
more so than ever now with twitter
tweeting out a thought or a joke or
uh you're not even rehearsing you're
creating
you're creating publicly right because
the comedy only becomes the joke only
becomes the joke when other people hear
it exactly right and this is what people
never seem to understand is in order for
comedians to be able to create new stuff
they have to go and try it and then find
out that a line has been crossed no one
knows where the line is until you go in
front of an audience and you say the
thing right and if you at that point
find out the line is too far and if we
now live in a culture where once you've
gone too far that's it there's someone
at your door
even approaching the line right you're
even talking about the right then all
that's gonna happen is comedians aren't
gonna go near the line they're not even
gonna get near it yeah and i think a lot
of them aren't doing that no so or
they're sticking to the topics but
to me there's no topic off limits so
you know
we're now in society we have all these
protected classes protected
lgbtqia plus
we're coddling that
group of people it's not a real
community at all but we're treating them
like children
and
and putting bubble wrap around them so
uh i was talking to someone the other
day and they said
you know chappelle's jokes are
anti-trans and i said did you like any
of the jokes he said yeah i liked that
one i said could it be that it's just a
joke that has a trans person in it and
it's not anti-trans and he said yeah
so why are you calling it anti-trans
then
so
th those topics are just growing i was
thinking of george carlin because he had
the seven words you can't say yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] piss [ __ ] sucker [ __ ] and
tits and i'm like if he lived today it
would be like the 700 topics
you can't talk about race gender gender
identity what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah
it would just be him listing it yeah and
i thought he almost had it better back
then with seven words he couldn't say
yeah now there's seven you know 70
topics all which have a hundred words uh
under the umbrella
uh but you just don't have to buy into
this make-believe world right and you'll
find out pretty quickly for me it was
about a year
being stuck at 3 000 followers
you know maybe 10 000 across platforms
and i i was doing good stuff i was doing
uh funny jokes and impressions and bill
burr and bill burr's
sharing them and jordan peterson but it
just was locked in a year it went to you
know surpassed 500 000
just from opening up the those
boundaries a little bit yeah well it's
because you're creating something no one
else is creating that's why yeah and i
bought most of the followers
but but you know what's really
interesting about what you were saying
it's that
comedy when i see it on tv particularly
you can push back if it's different in
america it's got to the stage where
memes on whatsapp and the chat you have
with your friends
is funnier than the comedy written and
made by professionals yeah absolutely
what's happening
[Music]
how did we get to that stage
it's all become
you know i i think everybody wants that
you know when you see comedian kind of
when that spills out into their act
people love it
uh it's just it's it's back to the the
fear we're letting a small minority of
extreme people
create the rules
and uh but they're made up right and we
are then enforcing the rules the comedy
industry enforces the rules exactly the
media enforces the rules yeah and
increasingly as we were talking before
we started in the uk it's actually
bleeding through into law we have laws
now about what you can and can't say we
have comedians who get investigated by
the police
right didn't somebody just get uh
arrested or something yeah well there
was a guy called joe liza for example he
had a call from the police a visit from
the police
because an audience member on his tour
complained and they were investigating
him to understand the joke we've had
people get calls from the police that's
funny
it's funny to you man
funny that that they'd have to
investigate and then you have to explain
your childhood they have to do a therapy
session like yeah i just got this image
in the police station and going yeah
yeah you know the pedophile okay still
stop stop someone made a joke yep
the murder investigation hold it put it
on hold this guy is making fun of uh
yeah overweight people
and then they have to do a deep dive
where did this come from well it started
when i was four my own my mom was fat
and my friends made fun of her and then
made a joke i got a laugh he's got to
tell this ten hour story how that became
a joke still gets arrested at the end of
it that's terrifying well right yeah
exactly and you wanted me to come do
stand up in the uk
i just wanted to it'd be great for your
career
you want a real litmus test to see
really what the limits are yeah exactly
we'll just put him on the stage it's
just you getting dragged off screen yeah
well someone of indiscriminate gender is
in the back crying
but but you know what that thing about
just
not playing by the fake rules it is so
free and this is what uh francis will
tell you like when we were still both
doing the circuit i always said to a man
you're funnier off stage than you are on
stage because you've you're driving with
the handbrake on that yeah yeah and
that's what most comedians do now
they're driving with the handbrake on
have you reminded him of that recently
i always say this to him this is why
he's gone crazy lately because he's
taking the handbrake off yeah
yeah and they just go what do you joke
about now francis and i tell them they
go okay and then i never hear from them
again yeah but like it's stopping people
from being the best version of the
comedian that they could be
and and i wonder what you know we've all
been through i suppose to some extent
but it's
i just know
that it is it just gives you so much
freedom to let go of that but it comes
with a lot of costs as you say man and i
think it's a trade-off that some people
can handle and a lot of people probably
can't yeah i'd say most probably can't
yeah yeah because it go you know it will
be family it will be because
what's so [ __ ] weird can i swear on
this no too late yeah it's close to free
speech in the uk if i do in a british
[ __ ] man
uh
it's uh
it's so
scary that
i mean i well i used to when i had when
i had thoughts uh that i didn't want to
even say i would part of why i did
impressions was i thought oh
if i'm bill burr and going oh these
[ __ ] feminists right i go on a date i
want a goddamn kill myself people would
laugh and i and i so i started to get a
lot of these ideas out
through
those people that's how hard it was for
me i had to
do that or you know i like to do trump
you know you know so many gender fluids
there's it's like everybody's wet
everybody's fluid and and everyone would
laugh people that hated
the the right would laugh at trump or or
laugh at him and that's how afraid i was
so it took me 10 years to even like
talk do a joke about my dad coming out
of the closet because i would get shamed
for
no even though your dad's gay you're a
straight white guy that's not your lived
experience
and so i had to
just sweat it out on stage and it is a
feeling i think a lot of people
you know don't want to go through
you know in the uk we have the edinburgh
festival which is how
in the in the old system that's how you
got discovered you put an hour show
together you had four minutes 40 minutes
of jokes you then did a little bit at
the 40th minute you said in professional
mates yeah 10 minutes of jokes 50
minutes of lecturing yeah exactly
talking about why your dad never loved
you and then you met this cat in india
that's where into your life and annette
started right yeah yeah that's how yeah
that is we have you to blame yes yeah
isn't she australian yeah yeah but but
we made her but the format is that yeah
and that's how you get discovered right
and so you go up there and then you get
nominated for awards and then the tv and
the radio people and then you get runs
in the west end right so that's how the
model works and the head of the awards
is a lady called nika burns right and in
2018 she said the words i'm looking
forward to the next generation of woke
comedians deciding what is and isn't
acceptable on the stage
and can we leave as well fine with that
yeah and this is the festival now all
right
we found out we found out
just this week that they are paying
to fly or transport whichever way they
do guardian journalists
to the festival
for them to see shows these are the same
guardian journalists to then go around
and review everything based on the
politics of the show as opposed to the
jokes in it wow
or what they've started doing now for
they did it in 2019 when i did my show
at edinburgh festival
it was doing really well and the
guardian came and on that night you're
like fellas dim the lights a little
bit
right and they came you happened to to
go very well on that night
and they didn't review it at all
this is how they do it now right so
these people are all working together in
a tiny little industry yeah
so what you went through i totally get
because that's how it works like you
stand up then you've got all of these
people against you the industry yeah
they they work as a whole so it's it's
all top down it's the you know it's what
honestly i can't say much about the
lawsuit but i i do feel bad
for these people you know this guy in
particular was a junior manager he's
probably you know brand new
and he's being told by the senior
managers i assume
is what he told me that
we're putting a cap on white people so
this poor guy has to come back and
report to me and it took him seven
months to be able to own up to it and i
also demanded
that he tell me the truth i said if
we're gonna get on the phone you have to
tell me why you've been dragging this
out for seven months
and so
god bless this
this guy and people are [ __ ] on him
too but he told he he actually is the
bravest right person i've come in
contact with because he told me the
truth but it's the
it's the movie studios
you know who are
tweeting hashtag you know gay ukrainian
black trans lives matter so let's get
that group cast then they're telling the
casting the directors casting directors
are calling the agents and the managers
and then it's the actors so
that is one big you know
solar system that works together and the
only way to get out of it is to do what
we're doing i think it is working itself
out yeah netflix put out a statement
that said if you're woke you might not
want to work here i mean that was coming
after putting out the wokest garbage you
can dream up for five ten years
well see i don't mind netflix putting
out work garbage as long as they don't
restrict other people from going on
there as well yeah but they did both
yeah yeah so that's why it got that's
why it was so one-sided it was anything
woke is gold also don't no white guys no
people of this you know
this uh
thought system or whatever it is so it
all just piled up
and and so if if you're not in that pile
and you're over here where everyone's
searching for comedy
it is kind of a the wild west right now
it's a gold rush i agree
and you know what's interesting is that
their ratings
are just going through the floor
all these shows that have embraced this
kind of agenda and this way of looking
at the world
it's all collapsing
but they
they don't seem to get their heads
around it and what's worse is that
they're like a comedian who's bombing
and they're going ah they're not liking
my [ __ ] pedo [ __ ] you know they're
you know this mother and baby audience
you know at two o'clock in an afternoon
let's double down
that's what they're doing starts
bringing the babies on stage yeah
but that's
it's a religion
it's a religion it's like being at
church halfway through the service
they're going you know what
jesus
he wasn't real
it wasn't real it's it's the same thing
this is a religion so it would be that
it would be akin to them going yeah that
never happened
there was never the boat with the
animals it's all [ __ ]
everyone would go wait
we've staked their whole lives on this
we've staked our career on it they're in
so deep
that the financial part
is is what's shifting it they're not
going to
magically change their values the the
the ratings are are going to force their
values to change back to hopefully
opening it back up but i'd like to see
i mean like andrew schultz just put out
his special
and he said uh streaming service
wanted to edit his jokes and he said
[ __ ] you and put it out himself we need
more people like that to do that 100 i
just produced my second special on my
own my first one's on youtube my next
one will be on youtube
uh and on my patreon but we're not even
i'm taking this so seriously we're not
even pitching to those places
that's how far away i want to be from
that yeah
and then you might not ever need it if
you build your your platform up enough
my goal is hopefully i don't ever need
to go
sit in a pitch with one of those places
again which i did for
six seven years with various tv shows
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies
he knows about that so will you in a
second
easy dns have rock solid network
infrastructure and fantastic customer
support they're in your corner no matter
what the world throws at you unless it's
your ex-girlfriend in which case you're
on your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com
forward slash triggered that's easy
dns.com forward slash triggered use our
promo code which is also triggered and
get 50 off the initial purchase sign up
for their newsletter access of easy
which tells you everything you need to
know about technology privacy and
censorship
you know what's interesting is what i
was very surprised about particularly
given we've spent about five days in new
york now we've met people we've gone to
comedy shows we talked to different
people in the comedy world like i was
surprised
that it seemed to me like in america
there's at least like enough comics who
see the ship for what it is
that you would have like a lot of
support as well publicly too
and
that doesn't seem to have transpired
really does it let me check my phone
[Music]
my dad hasn't texted yeah no no publicly
no i don't think
from what i could tell i don't think any
any comedians have
maybe a few maybe
five tops
have publicly and i don't need someone
to publicly do it i mean no you don't
but society does
otherwise you're just the one racist guy
who can't handle being one right it
would help it would help right but maybe
five maybe five out of i'm in a i'm in a
uh
system of about
5 000 comedians
and i mean like if a new if a comedian
friends me on facebook we have five
thousand mutual friends
across the country
so
i don't know what five out of five
thousand is if you have glasses on you
might know
this one
that's one in a thousand yeah yeah but
it's just so sad man because you know
what the great part is and i was
thinking about this the other day and i
have i haven't said this out loud the
best part about it
is and you guys know this now that you
have
some success
uh or a lot of success
uh people will start to ask for favors
and butter butter up to you and
and uh
whatever british term you have for that
yeah
suck up brown nose is the other one
brown nose
this is one benef benefit i didn't
anticipate
nobody
asks me for anything
ever
they don't brown nose me they don't suck
up they don't ask to go on my podcast
they don't ask to be in a sketch nothing
and that is that is one of those little
perks that you wouldn't really imagine
being so
amazing because that could also take out
uh actors comedians people in the
entertainment business johnny carson uh
for instance became you know completely
isolated because everybody wanted
something from him at all times
i can walk into a comedy club and sit
down and work on my jokes go up kill and
walk out
and not one person maybe more than a
like
a wing yeah it's brilliant
so i've found that as well like i walk
in and like people just look at me and
i'm like
have i just like got a covered positive
test on my head everyone's like get the
man or like four in the shape of a
swastika yeah four
or my favorite one is when people go to
talk to me they do this
anyway
you're like did i leave the house in
blackface today
oh [ __ ] man
you know it the thing is it also still
happens though i remember when i turned
down that contract there was a guy who
like really didn't like it was attacking
me on my own like feeds and whatever
replying and then like three days later
when it became a big news story and it
was became like public and people cared
about it he messaged me saying you know
what i'd love to talk to you about this
should we go for a coffee
and i was like didn't you spend like
three days just attacking me endlessly i
was like yeah yeah i'll go and delete
that
did you call him out for it uh publicly
no i said it i said to him right yeah i
said to him you you've been saying
you've been talking [ __ ] about me for
three days now you want to go for a
coffee what happened and he went oh no
no i'll go delete all those posts now
man so did you have the coffee we never
got around to it i was happy to do it
but it just it was interesting to me
that somebody would flip the switch in
about
three days well that you you reached the
point of notoriety like where were you
in your career at that point no not that
far right so that probably gave you a
little bump yeah and that is another
thing i'm seeing there is like an
algorithm to it where you cross a
certain number of followers or whatever
it is
where then p like i have some people
coming back around now yes yeah for the
first time
saying
i'm proud of you congratulations wow you
have
this
and i go where was that when i was dying
and i was you know that would have been
a useful
you know text at that point yeah yeah
like so this is what i find interesting
as well you know so you get some of
these comedians who are openly overtly
work
until something happens
or a particular topic but there's a
comedian who i helped a lot at the early
stages of his career because i helped
her run a comedy club and he was very
woke and vice did a hit piece on the
comedy club that i was this was ricky
gervais right yeah exactly right right i
love what that's how long he's been
around yeah man he loves how you crafted
him yeah uh and uh and he liked that the
vice hit piece and all the rest of it
then i bumped into him in a comedy club
and you know i was because i'm passive
aggressive
he pushed her away yeah exactly and if
we were talking he looked at me he went
i'm not gonna get the vaccine mate
and i went really and he went yeah
because you know here's the reasons why
i had a friend she took it she got very
sick she had really bad side effects and
ever since then it freaked me out and i
just don't want anything to do with it
but he said it under his breath when he
knew that no one was around right also
like you're his physician or something
it's like just because you have a thing
doesn't mean that people now have to
come to you and go yeah yeah and i was
and i just said to him i was like it
doesn't matter what you do it doesn't
matter how [ __ ] pure you are they're
going to get you on something yeah and
that was his thing and you could tell
like the penny had dropped it doesn't
matter how pure no
you don't do one thing it doesn't will
happen it will happen and so why not and
i know like you said mark was on your
show yeah and i had mark on my podcast
uh when i first started it
and i i kind of was like how do you
you really go for it you know and i
always loved watching him go for it and
he just said like
hey hey i just no i'm not gonna do it
he said i'm gay he he said i just i just
do it all the time this is how i am all
the time on every podcast every tweet
that way people can't point to that one
thing
and so that did really that was one of
the things that helped me go all right
i'm gonna do this for everything all the
time
so they can't find that one little thing
there's thousands what are you gonna do
print out the ten thousand things like
that they're just gonna pick the
highlights man we're waiting for the
guardian hit piece it's coming it's
coming for everybody yeah but i think
you'll have a you know that's the thing
you build your own following up to a
certain size when they come for you if
you didn't do anything illegal mm-hmm
you're looking for a way
no we've got a great legal team man
don't worry about it they will have your
back and right because of locals patreon
yeah you know crystal is a great example
yeah right i mean he didn't do anything
illegal as far as i'm concerned
he had you know he cheated on his
fiancee shame on you he did a lot of bad
things but he apologized he went and got
help and went to i think 12-step
programs and stuff and sure enough there
his following was
to to kind of lift him back up and pay
his bills
and
there you go no man i it makes it makes
perfect sense and that's the beauty of
the moment that's why
i am
somewhat more positive than i have been
for a long time yeah about everything
that's happening because at least i
always get i find it very difficult when
i think there's no way out
and as my dad always says a situation
with no way out is a situation where you
don't like the obvious way out
and the obvious way out is just to go
[ __ ] you and build something of your own
right but that's hard
that's scary that's difficult you're
going to take a lot of [ __ ] yeah it's
going to be a challenge which has been
for you it's been for us whatever you
know speaking of mark norman the
interesting difference i suppose between
what he said and what you've said to us
is he was saying look the way to deal
with this is just to ignore it you just
do your thing you just ignore it but you
felt you had to make a stand and go out
of the comedy persona and into the real
world and go actually this is wrong no
here's a joke about how this i agree i
agree with mark and mark does that so
well and i think that is to
bring him incredible longevity with his
career
but like we talked about off camera
earlier um
as well as your pedophile lawsuit
that you're trying to find the easy way
out
well i go to look after france
is
you know there was a a defining moment
for me and that was
me not getting the vaccine which i
thought
was a personal choice that nobody else
would know about i don't i never talked
about personal stuff in my life again
even being like
my dad is gay was the scariest thing to
do on stage
uh i remember you i even talked about
being uncircumcised once and a bartender
at the show goes stop stop it
no
and uh it was like another year before i
even you know did that bit again
uh
i had to cut it out no pun intended
the difference for me was when that
happened
uh i decided i'm not gonna lie to the
comedy clubs and say that i got the
vaccine because i respect them you know
these clubs uh that i had it took me 12
years to get into finally gave me a shot
and i you know i really showed up i wore
a suit i posted on the weekends started
to make a living and so i felt i owed
them the truth
and so i just said i'm not going to lie
i'm not going to make the fake card
that was the difference for me that's
when it had to become personal because
then i got attacked
why don't you just lie what what are you
doing why don't you get the vaccine and
it and it became like
it crossed the line where it's like no
this is now my personal medical choice
this is different than
comedy or jokes you make
this is a personal
uh
my body my choice thing which is ironic
because i'm i actually am all for my
body my choice
and so it's interesting to be called
right wing
far right to have a stance that's
as pure as it can be with my body my
choice across the board so so that's
where it really shifted
uh and then i had to sort of by default
talk about my personal stuff
because people were going in and kind of
pulling it out but i had never had any
intention to to talk about that i was at
those clubs when there was no vaccine
nobody knew what it was i was one of
like
few comedians that were willing to go
perform
which actually felt like a risk to your
health but i just thought i'll die if i
don't do it and the crowd needs it and
the crowds were small and it was outside
and everyone's in their mask and face
shield and the comedians are the only
ones up there no mask no vaccine so then
suddenly
after working for a year for free
all the money they made went to their
chefs and to their bus boys and stuff
they didn't give any to the comedians
i worked for free and then one day
they're like nope you're out of here
and i just thought man
you know now i now i have to to to build
this on my own and that just sort of
opened up a little bit of a window for
me to start talking about more personal
stuff never would have happened
for if it weren't for for um that
vaccine divisiveness
it's so which blows my mind and i lost a
ton of friends
and family
not allowed in my family's house
probably still to this day
so it was like a tremendous
loss that i never
intended to uh
to to go near
what why do you think the whole vax
issue was so divisive
i think it was done on i think it was
done on purpose
to prevent trump from getting reelected
again and it worked
what do you mean by that
i mean it became political it was
not a political issue no because also by
the way if you even take this thing out
and dissect it even a little bit trump's
the one that pushed the vaccine that got
the regulations
uh reduced because that's what he's good
at building skyscrapers without any you
know hey boys the ground's not level
he's like just build it it's fine it's
on a slant it's the slanted tower we'll
call it the slanted
even though that's racist
and so
[Laughter]
so it's so it's so mind-boggling because
you're going this is trump's vaccine
this is his baby i'm not getting it and
i'm now being called the far right wing
trump supporting extremist
my head is going to explode it was it
was
divided for a purpose and then it was
easy to go oh the far right wingers
they're the ones that don't care about
saving the planet or saving the elderly
and i think that divide into those two
camps worked so good and is now
the norm for everything in society is
that joke on the right people even i'll
do shows in florida and someone will go
hey i love your conservative stuff i
love that you do conservative comedy
no i'm didn't you just hear i just made
fun of trump and biden i made fun of the
left and the right
and that vaccine [ __ ] has now
created these two camps that it it's
gonna
be a miracle to
to break out of that you know that's so
interesting you said that i had that at
a gig where i was doing lots and i like
to comment on politics and what's
happening both
i tend to find myself more on the left
so on the right for certain things like
i think women exist you know that kind
of thing
you know i i think controversial you
know what i mean i think if you've got
you know you know boom with tits in a
vagina that makes you a woman yeah you
know i'm kind of far right like what are
you trying to do bananas off youtube
i know you know so i think but a lot of
the stuff i'm sort of center center left
well soon you're gonna it's gonna be
more like chauvinistic you're not gonna
be able to say woman you're gonna have
to go yeah yeah yeah
one of those old chess feeders
leaders and chess feeders that's how you
know yeah and like and i i did the staff
and whatever else and i was talking
about whatever i was talking about
there's a new material and i came out
and i went okay that worked that didn't
and this guy came up to me and was just
like i really liked your conservative
comedy you know i like it's like that
right comment like right wing comedy i
liked it i'm like that's not me
and then like and then
the same thing this black guy came up to
him went the racial stuff was good you
know
what what the [ __ ] is going on do you
know what i mean
like 10 years ago this would have just
been kind of another guy's like i love
the proud boys
i love the woke far left slightly right
androgynous
yeah genderqueer material like what
why
we've got to this thing the though
that's fox news and cnn they that they
have uh they owe everybody a
sum of money for that yeah because it
became the two camps and as soon as i
stopped watching cnn people go oh so
you're a far-right fox guy now it's like
hello what about the 99 in the middle
can we explore this for a little bit
yeah
and uh but you got to be firm you can't
you can't i just did a film with the
daily wire yeah and um just because you
know ben shapiro is
um a conservative and by the way this is
brought to you by expressvpn i have to
say that get 20 off
because
because he hit the owner's conservative
uh people are like oh you're in that
conservative western film
it's like this was a this was a classic
western film what there were no trump
rallies uh you know on horses or
anything you know um you know make
horses great again there was no
it was just a western film yeah and
another a great easy target for
comedians too like oh can you believe
he's doing this far-right film i'm like
that was the only movie offer i've ever
gotten in my life and i've been
auditioning
for 17 years
probably thousands of times
i don't have options
and just because it's the daily wire
doesn't mean it's this thing and so
hopefully that company will continue to
make uh films that are just good
um
i love that i love their attitude that
conservative thing i'm not hate to break
too but disney they're not the good guys
you know it's funny yeah if you actually
met a lot of the owners of these
corporations most of them are likely
conservative because they like no one in
custody excuse me not when it comes to
sexual pregnancy
that's true they're very liberal in that
one yeah
that's have you no now okay so have you
noticed a difference between
london and new york as far as walking
around and going i don't know what
could that be a man or a woman or and
i'm not even being you know malicious
here but it's i'm genuinely
confused yeah uh oftentimes
and it's it's a confusing time to live
in everything is confusing yeah you know
what i mean like it's confusing in ways
that you don't know what you can joke
about anymore what was acceptable
like a week ago isn't it acceptable now
like you can see you a year ago you
could have made this joke but now like
we've all got examples of jokes this is
why i like what tyler's saying though is
like we just all got to stop giving a
[ __ ] yeah you really do and and back to
your finding the positive part of it
yeah there is a moment when you have to
just go all right things are going good
for us right now yeah let's ride that
wave you could still make fun of
obviously because that's there's a
wealth of material
and when people go you're on the right
now i said no i made fun of trump for
four years
there's a new guy in town he happens to
be dem a democrat he also happens to be
dying in front of our eyes
of apparently cancer and dementia and
all these things you know
you're a comedian that go where the the
gold is you have so much gold here well
this is why boris johnson the
conservative party leader in our country
we're supposed to be right-wing we were
taking the piss out of him for the
entire time he was in office sure right
because that's what you're supposed to
[ __ ] do yeah you're a comedian you're
supposed to and if particularly if
you're political as we both are you're
supposed to make fun of the thing that's
happening that's your job yeah right
you're not you're not on a team you're
not you're not a pro labor comedian or a
pro
concert but but a lot of people pick
that team and then they have the [ __ ]
audacity to say that because we refuse
to pick a team we picked the wrong team
exactly that's how it works right they
picked the left team right and we're
going we're just going to be objective
in the middle of it which makes us the
evil guys on the right exactly yeah yeah
that's how they've done it a lot of it
started i don't think a lot of people
made fun of obama i think that was the
beginning of there's certain people
based on what they look like that you
can't make fun of and i think i
certainly took a break for eight years
making fun of politics i i
plenty made fun of george bush before of
course i mean obama was a very different
character to bush he had whatever you
think of his policies he had an air of
respectability he was a great orator he
was presidential yeah he wasn't making
up words like bush who just kind of yeah
you know it's fantastic it's wonderful
it's wonderful wondertastical
just daily making up for us yeah obama
was cool but i was still afraid to make
fun of you oh but that's this is the
other part i was coming to which is i
think a lot of people and i include
myself on this invested all our sort of
like all that time we spent jerking off
over martin luther king we we channeled
that into obama you know right right
like he was the vision that we'd all
been working to finally we'd arrived at
this great society by the way you don't
hear about martin luther king anymore no
no he's he's racist but he's a coconut
coconut yeah i mean i yeah that's why
but this is my point like all of us who
were just like
i don't want to live in a racist society
i want society to move forward i want us
to get to a point where anyone of any
race can do anything that's the dream
that our generation that's what we were
looking towards right and then this guy
comes along and he and he's you know
he's a great speaker he he manages to
persuade a hell of a lot of people he's
clean as joe biden said yeah right
and then everyone sort of invests into
that because we think finally look look
we just shut up about like we've done it
we got there we're in a good place we're
in a healthy place i think that's why a
lot of people
were extra careful about him because
he's like don't don't [ __ ] with this
great thing that we finally got to sure
well that's also what
it's just interesting because he's he's
a black man he's also just as much a
white man as he is a black man so it's
like with you we can conveniently choose
when he's white when he's black it's
more like francis actually because
francis is obviously half venezuelan his
mother's very dark woman okay he's
turned out like this obama's kind of
like that yeah i am like obama mate you
know what i mean it's always been my
fantasy to bomb the [ __ ] out of the
middle east
but but it's it's the way we racially
categorize people that it's just so
ridiculous yeah man it just is it's it's
starting to eat itself up i i'm telling
comedians who kind of secretly come to
me now i go just sit back and enjoy the
show
because ever if there's a new rule every
day that no one's approved of it's all
starting to eat itself up
you know and a great example was
we had a uh
not a barista a guy at a bodega or a
bogoda as jill biden calls it yeah um a
lot of taco people eat there a lot of
bread you'll find a lot of breakfast
tacos eating tacos at the bogadas a guy
who was uh i believe middle eastern or
something uh was attacked by a black man
right yeah and the the guy's
girlfriend even came in and tried
stabbing the the middle eastern guy the
the guy was given a knife and stabbed
and killed the black guy yeah so okay
this is a case of self-defense this is a
new thing racism no white person
involved yeah so what do you do
well the the less dark guy got punished
even though he was defending he got he
was charged with murder yeah i mean the
thing is on tape it is as clear as as
day and so to me i go here comes the
real show because now
what do you do when there's no white
person to blame now you have to pick one
because that's what they're in the
business of doing well if you do justice
on the basis of people's skill kind of
skin color instead of what they've
actually done then you eventually get to
this point exactly it gets that
ridiculous
uh and i'm sorry i was just gonna say
and also i know that here in new york in
terms of uh
compensation and support that was
offered to people post lockdown that was
racially yes allocated and coleman
hughes who was sitting in that chair
only yesterday explained i just met him
too yeah explained basically how
wha if you were white you didn't get
anything and if you were from a
different demographic then you did like
it's gonna it's gonna get to a point
where it's just ridiculous like you say
with this product well when it gets
personal too so everyone's gonna have to
hit their like woke
rock bottom right woke bottom whatever
you want to call it that's that's what
it is you're gonna reach a point and
it's gonna likely be financial or you
were a job was taken away or your
daughter's job it's like the people that
come after me i go well what if yeah
what if your white daughter was told
[ __ ] off you're white you can't be an
actor yeah you're just gonna like let
that go and so it it's gonna reach a
point in everyone's life
where it's too much i had a gay
lit gay a colombian or something he was
gay and something else not white let's
just it's easy to say that gay not white
comedian
reach out to me
got a tv offer for a tv show but he
looked too white they told him
so he's gay he's colombian but he wasn't
dark enough so it was going to be a
tough sell for them so yeah we know you
think but
yeah and i think that was you that dna
yeah uh
and so
you know that was both shocking and not
shocking to get that message from him
because
i make fun of everyone including anyone
who's gay or not gay or whatever so
classically he would not be someone
reaching out to me or wanting support
but he reached out for some support
and so here i am a white guy offering
support to a gay colombian guy who
didn't get the job because he can
reference that i'm talking about this
and taking legal action so
it's the tide has already gone back i
think a lot of comedians a lot of people
are still going into this tidal wave
that's actually already on the way back
and we're up here swimming it'd be nice
you know if the ocean was a little
colder in here but okay we're swimming
we're swimming with the tide i think
yeah it's an interesting way to look at
it it is a very interesting way to look
at it i think the the
the reason as well a lot of people are
starting to wake up it's just because
the trans [ __ ] is so insanely mental
[Laughter]
but it's just so insane you're just
listening to what them saying like
anyone can be a woman if i identify as a
woman i'm a woman you're like
come on and there's no such thing as a
woman yeah that's the thing it's fun
we're watching these these car wrecks
every day
where their two made up ideas are just
colliding and it's so fun it is it is a
lot the women's march i don't know if
you saw this they tweeted today saying a
transparent women hear about the women's
march i was at the chess feeding uh
birthing first in march the belita
convention yeah
you were at the bleeder convention
anyway i like the the positive note that
you
that we had there for a second before
francis took it in a negative direction
as you want to uh
it's good to end on a positive note and
i think you're right i think the the
tide is
helpful to where we are um but it's
going to take a long time for other
people to catch up i think yeah it's
going to take some time uh tyler it's
been great having you on before we ask
you a couple of questions from our
supporters that only they get to see
sure uh the last question join locals
sorry joan locals and see those answers
there uh the last question we always ask
is what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that you
think we really should be in america or
england wherever you want more here's a
great one back to the joke that the the
bartender told me not to say
is
the uh execution of the tip of
the penis
formerly known as circumcision
in america
it's uh it's so taboo to even talk about
it
and uh and so for me that's something
i'm trying to talk about more i have a
joke about it in my new special
because i was made fun of as a kid for
not uh being circumcised right and the
more research i do i find out wait a
minute funny enough
uh it's there's the reason that skin is
on the penis so what is that like in
england is it common it's not it's not
it's more common far more common to be
uncertain okay prove it
[Laughter]
so here we go yeah yeah so so that's uh
i i find to be very interesting because
it's so taboo here yeah and you have
parents going i don't want anyone
vaccinating my kids or doing anything
medical yet their baby comes out and
they go you want us to cut his dick off
they go yeah take them and they're
letting that happen
i think they're doing circumcision wrong
in america if that's what they're doing
you're just cutting this dick up yeah
we cut off the left ball yeah and the
tip yeah you want them to be right wing
yeah you take off the ball that's how we
get it back centered yeah but but in
america it's it is so taboo and i tell
you when i talk about on stage people
are sweating and they're terrified
and uh and
i tell the story my in my special but i
i
all of our friends drew pictures of
their penises uh with chalk on the black
top and it was all you know round
penises and i drew mine as a triangle
trying to represent you know i was only
eight
and they were like what the [ __ ] is that
is that a witch's hat is that an
elephant trunk and so i started to get
bullied from eight years
eight years old on
uh and i even
it's the reason i dropped out of college
really yes because i was dating a woman
i was so afraid of her seeing my penis
because
in pop culture we make fun of it on
seinfeld it's it's known as this like
horrendous monster dick
and i was so afraid
to show her my penis and then i became
depressed and i lost my and i dropped
out of school
wow and that's let me tell you something
man there is nothing wrong with a
triangular penis exactly thank you
there's nothing wrong with going full
sharpening my friend exactly uh
tyler fisher so great to have you on uh
where can people find your stuff online
uh uncircumcised.com
it's a support group we're trying to get
uncut well my jokes are uncut you can go
to tylerfisher.com
it's f-i-s-c-h-e-r i have a patreon
tyler talks patreon.com tylertalks uh my
comedy special will be out on patreon in
the next few weeks and then uh all
social media platforms tie the fish t-y
the f-i-s-c-h
and just look for the um the witch's cap
is my
penis is my penis yeah picture fantastic
stuff tyler thanks so much for coming on
thank you guys for watching we'll see
you and listening of course we'll see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or a raw show all
of them go out at 7pm uk time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast
take care and see you soon guys and join
locals comedy
[Music]
please ask him if he do his bill burr
impression until a nearly six foot
highlander it's brutal
[Music]
you